[Music]
well today we cancel men's health
magazine which is a publication
at this point as concerned with helping
men be healthy as say planned parenthood
is with planning parenthood but perhaps
the better comparison is with the
magazine scientific american which as we
saw a couple weeks ago has completely
abandoned science and replaced it with
delusional lgbt propaganda men's health
has undergone a similar process of
devolution as evidenced by its advice
column sexplanet written by a guy named
zachary zane now zack
whose picture we'll put up on the screen
for reference uh describes himself in
his bio as
a sex writer author and ethical boy [ __ ]
now zach had to add the word ethical
there because he had decided that the
term boy [ __ ] was somehow not stupid and
embarrassing enough on its own
this is of course the one skill that
most leftists still possess
they're always finding increasingly
inane ways describing themselves
and just when you think that they've
come up with with a label so bizarre in
asinine that it could not possibly be
topped
they come along and drop ethical boy
[ __ ]
so zach goes on explaining that um
in his bio he says over the years i've
had my fair share of sexual experiences
dating and sleeping with hundreds of
people of all genders and orientations
in doing so i've learned a thing or two
about navigating issues in the bedroom
and a bunch of other places tbh i'm here
to answer your most pressing sex
questions with thorough actionable
advice
there's no doubt of course that he has
learned how to navigate certain issues
in the bedroom for example i'm sure you
could tell us which topical ointment is
best for treating monkey pox sores but
outside of managing the side effects of
the many dozens of diseases this man has
most likely contracted over the years
it's not clear what advice he really has
to offer
or what anyone would uh why anybody
would try to solicit it in the first
place
and yet some people do allegedly like
the guy who sent in
this question for the most recent
edition of his sex planet column
so someone going by the by the moniker
labels are hard writes quote
dear sexplanted if i'm sexually
attracted to people afab which stands
for assigned female at birth because of
anatomy does that make me pansexual my
whole life i've identified as a straight
man because i'm sexually attracted to
women's bodies but if i'm attracted to
someone afab who goes who comes out as a
trans man but doesn't choose surgery
does that make me pan or buy i'm not
attracted to people amab uh assigned
male birth but i am certain that uh tran
but i am to certain trans men and nbs
which means non-binary by the way if i
change my sexual orientation i feel bad
as if i'm just pretending so i can
encompass their gender identity to be
with them
now before we get to zac's answer
it's worth noting that the person who
wrote this question
just a small detail here almost
certainly doesn't exist
and i know that because advice
columnists frequently invent questions
and also because
no straight man in the world
feels guilty about being straight first
of all as this person seems to nor would
any straight man feel that his
orientation and sexual behavior requires
the blessing of a gay guy in a mesh
t-shirt
there is just
no heterosexual in existence
who's ever said to himself you know i
think it's okay that i'm attracted to
the female form but i better check with
an ethical boy [ __ ] first
no this is a question that mr zane has
come up with
because he has some thoroughly
unsolicited advice that he wants to
offer on the subject and here's what he
says
quote
your attractions technically meet the
definition of bisexuality since you're
attracted to vulva owners of multiple
genders but i don't think you're really
struggling with how you personally
identify it sounds like you know you
might be fetishizing people with a vulva
and you're wondering how to do that
without offending people especially
potential partners who are trans or
non-binary good
this is something you should care about
did you get that if you're attracted to
somebody if you're attracted to one sex
then you're bisexual
one has become two
bad news for all the circus performers
who've been training on the unicycle
their whole lives
was all a waste of time because every
unicycle is now a bicycle let me ask you
something what if there was uh someone
out there who kept a log of every single
thing you did every minute of the day i
think that'd be pretty creepy well what
if i told you that's exactly what
happens every time you go online your
internet provider like att or comcast is
allowed to store logs of every website
you've ever visited and can legally sell
this data to anybody you want that's why
i always use
expressvpn expressvpn reroutes your
internet connection through their secure
server so your internet provider can't
see or log what you do online
now many of you might be wondering uh if
i'm routing all my data through a vpn
that does not just mean that vpn can log
all my data and you're right to think
that many vpns claim to have a no logs
policy but have been caught logging
customer activity anyway expressvpn is
the only vpn i trust because they use
trusted server technology stop letting
people keep logs of what you do online
visit expressvpn.com
mattwall show right now and find out how
you can get three months free at
expressvpn
matt walsh show now
words have no meaning
numbers have no meaning
zach continues there's nothing wrong
with having a fetish for a certain body
part i for example have a fetish for
huge asses
but it's offensive to reduce a person to
that soul body part in this case their
vulva unless the person is especially
explicitly open to being fetishized in
that way i love when i find a person who
wants me to worship their ass or wants
me to use them because as the gay boys
say i'm just a whole sir
the real key key here isn't picking the
right label for your orientation if you
list yourself with buy and start
matching with trans men and envies you
can't go around asking them if they have
a penis or a vulva down there that's not
only rude but also potentially
triggering for people with gender gender
and body dysmorphia so go ahead and call
yourself bisexual to expand your pool of
potential partners but you must also
make it crystal clear in your dating app
bio that you're only looking for people
with a vulva this way you know uh the
people who swipe right on you are
clearly okay with your preferences and
the people who aren't can safely swipe
left i hope you find someone who gets
just as turned on by you reducing them
to their vulva but i'll be real with you
the majority of people cis and trans
aren't down to be fetishized
your search will be slow going but at
least you won't have to feel bad about
pretending anymore
so to review
people attracted to one sex are bisexual
women are mere vulva owners
homosexual heterosexuality rather is a
potentially offensive fetish
and straight men are ethically bound to
announce themselves because there are
some people who may not be okay with
that preference
this is also demented and ridiculous
that it may seem unworthy of any
response at all and perhaps it is but on
the other hand conservatives have made
the mistake of not responding to lots of
demented things over the years until one
day they realize that they probably
should have offered some sort of
response earlier and now it's too late
so on that note i will make a couple of
observations here
first
we see here again the resentment and
hatred that the lgbt left has for women
never mind the phrase volva owner
doesn't even make sense
because your body parts are not objects
that you own
okay
they are the things that physically
comprise you
they're part of you
they are you
right like my hand is not it's not just
this this thing that i went and bought
at a store
hey uh if you cut my hand off i wouldn't
say hey no don't take that i own that
well that's that's me that's my body
that's that's who i am
now the greater point here is that they
insist that women shouldn't be reduced
to their genitals even as they do
exactly that
as always they're the ones doing the
thing they accuse everyone else of doing
projection that's all they do
so the boy [ __ ] here says that if a man
is attracted to women
he must be attracted solely for her
genitals that's because zach himself
sees women as nothing but genitals like
with a body and brain attached
but in reality a man is attracted to a
female's body
that's true and it's a good thing that
he is because without that attraction
the human species wouldn't exist
a zac himself would not exist if it
wasn't for a long line of men before him
who were according to him vulva fetishes
but that's not the full story
a man is is attracted to a female's body
but is also attracted to everything else
about her
right her personality just the way she
is the way she carries herself the way
she speaks the way she sounds
the totality of her of her feminine
presence
we see women as much more than
reproductive organs and we are drawn in
by the whole experience the whole
package
the lgbt left on the other hand denies
that there is anything more to a woman
than her genitals and then says that
even the genitals don't matter
and they do all of this simply so that
men can partake in and appropriate
womanhood
they reduce women
and ultimately erase them
and then accuse us of doing exactly what
they have just done themselves
second get ready get ready here for
another shift right because living in a
society run by the left means that
you're you're standing on cultural
tectonic plates that are constantly
moving around
shifting jostling often creating huge
earthquakes that can all at once
completely change the landscape
so here it is happening again
for decades
the left worked to remove
the stigma from fetishes and normalize
all uh sexual proclivities and
preferences they said that nobody should
feel ashamed of who they love or who
they're attracted to
and they largely succeeded in this
project and created exactly the sort of
profligate shameless society they wanted
but now they've changed their minds
because now they say actually a fetish
is shameful and unnatural it turns out
that not all sexual proclivities are
acceptable it's just that
heterosexuality that is the preference
quote unquote that sustains human life
and upon which human civilization
depends
is the shameful unacceptable fetish
victorian prudishness is rapidly coming
back into style except in this kind of
deranged demonic form
it is exactly what is natural and
healthy and life-sustaining which is now
stigmatized
they insisted that the doors be flung
open in the name of inclusion
and they got their way
and they were invited inside
and then they immediately proceeded to
kick everybody else out
and shut and lock the very doors that
they were just demanding be opened
inclusiveness is the ultimate trojan
horse
if only everybody else would stop
falling for it
and also stop reading men's health
magazine
if anyone actually does read it which i
kind of doubt but at any rate it is
today cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts